let's see what I say fashion show just  pretend this is the catwalk some  agencies I think Oh looks like the  neighbors are still having parties left  and right we have to call the cops on  them I suppose  is this a homeless what the hell is  going on what are you waving at Oh  foreigner that's for sure  wah wah whee-wah what the hell is this  Borat excuse me that's my yard I so want  nothing now what the hell is this what  one next Mario and it's Luigi I work for  a living I don't have Candyland dreams  like you two idiots you know Watchers  like you know I don't know what her  cultures like I want to stop just be  accepting of different cultures okay  okay I mean thinking our son yes yes he  doesn't look like us it and I always  questioned that right we've all  questioned it yep look she if she's  gonna live here